Kendall and Courtney hit the high seas  [Music]  the kardashian-jenner girls are enjoying  their time at the Cannes Film Festival  looking ultra chic in some yacht ready  fashions  Kendall opted for a pair of high-waisted  cream pants and a nautical top while  Courtney slipped into a strapless white  sundress really cute  the sisters shared more fashion details  over on snapchat showing off their  coordinated of pink heels they also  slipped into some swimsuits showing off  these black and white Beach looks on  Instagram family friend Simon Huck  shared this shot on his story  paddleboarding while Kendall soaks up  the Sun I mean it's awesome  you